hellbent I gotta be honest guys I don't
really know what to make of this thing I
mean I'm I'm fairly certain I don't like
it but yeah yeah I can't even say some
reasons why but at the same time I feel
like I can't properly judge this thing
cuz I don't think I really understand
what it is or what it's trying to be I
mean I said well if I were to take the
sort of the best-case-scenario
comparison the first time I saw Vincent
and the doctor I didn't love it I
dislike it but I didn't do a lot for me
on a rewatch I like that much better
because I understood what it was going
for sort of the more pessimistic end of
that is time of the doctor which I also
liked better on the re-watch but still
never have come to love and maybe if I
give this thing a second viewing it'll
work better but right now I don't know
you know I didn't really know what to
expect or what I wanted coming out of
Heaven Sent but I wasn't expecting this
it I mean ultimately it became about
Clara which is so weird to me because
she had a perfectly good send-off two
episodes ago and good odd she has had
more perfectly he could send offs then
it she's had more perfectly good send
offs than Rory had deaths I mean maybe
not quite but it sure sure feels like
that she had a perfectly good send-off
at the end of death in heaven then she
had a perfectly good send-off at the end
of last Christmas she had a perfectly
good send-off that involved her dying in
face the Raven and and then in in Heaven
Sent we had wonderful little sort of
memorial notes on her and now she's back
kind of but still got why I feel like
I've I've just watched what happens when
a creator is too in love with their own
creation because what it really feels
like is that Steven Moffat fell in love
with Clara
on a level that I i certainly as an
audience member never did and I really
feel like Steven Moffat must have
because other than being completely
enamored with this character I can't
think of any reason why you would do
what this episode does and that's not
all that's weird I mean all the stuff
ahead of cars show me up is with the
stuff on Gallifrey is weird
we get Rassilon back which I called I'm
still a little disappointed that it
wasn't Timothy Dalton but you know I can
dig that it somebody older maybe it was
the effects of the master blasting him
maybe he had to regenerate who knows but
the actor while I know him from Game of
Thrones and I actually really liked him
and that he doesn't have the gravitas or
the waiter this sort of hints that
Timothy Dalton had so that was a little
disappointing
all the people on Gallifrey who weren't
like in the military or part of the High
Council being dressed like it was the
frontier land and again I don't I really
don't think I understood what it was
trying to do or the things that keep
going my head that maybe I see what I
was trying to do I don't see why it
would do those things like I get that
like they're there show me how far the
doctor would go for Clara but I don't
think that it shows anything about him
that we didn't already see I mean we saw
a lot of the same elements of like him
breaking rules in something like water
of Mars but I mean you know in that case
it was more the principle of the thing
rather than for a specific person but
you know I feel like I've seen them all
the aspects that this episode seems to
be bringing out and forgotten they had
to rehash the idea of somebody losing
their memory I mean slightly clever
having you be the doctor this time
instead of the companion but again we
already saw that with Donna and the
things that are completely new I don't
like I don't like that the doctor shot
somebody I don't care that he knew that
he was gonna regenerate I don't like
that I do kind of like in that giving us
another gender swap regeneration it's
clear that when this character was the
man that was the exception rather than
becoming female I mean that was kind of
nice and maybe the
purpose of that was to was to have it go
a step beyond how he pushed the boundary
in waters of Mars but are we just
pushing the boundary for the sake of it
or is it again because Steven Moffat is
just so in love with Clara and he's made
the doctor so in love with Clara that
he's willing to go that distance and I
did I'm really kind of tired of the
doctor getting so enamored of his
companions I get that the commands are
important to him and I would never argue
that they aren't but throughout his
history so many companions have come and
gone and I and I can get the argument
that you know later his life he sort of
cherishes those connections more than
when he was younger and he didn't
understand their weight and their value
but this this is getting a hold I don't
know guys I just I just don't know the
whole thing is just so weird to me I'll
be curious to see what people think I
and if you know people get it maybe I
can figure out what's going on but there
are random bits that I like the
performances are fine Maisie Williams
was good but the whole thing is just
weird
so what for you has been the weirdest
viewing experience Doctor Who episode
the one that you've watched you like I
don't get it whatever it is drop
something down in the comments and let's
let's talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned